want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you two you have michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
how you can invest in crypto
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one balance your portfolio with where
will paul what does your portfolio look
like right now i know uh you were kind
of all bitcoin then you went bitcoin and
ether uh what does that look like today
so we just understand the perspective
you're coming from
um my current allocation is probably 70
eth 5 bitcoin
and then a tale of
others
so why that allocation there's nothing
against bitcoin it's not against
anything else it's because i'm a
financial markets guy and we use risk
curves
so at certain points in the cycle in the
middle of a bull market you want to take
as much risk as possible so you want to
go to the
more speculative end of the market
so
firstly you know i isolated the fact
that i thought ethereum was going to see
further flows it's early in this
adoption cycle and that will probably
drive prices further than bitcoin and
that seems to be playing out
with the others there's so much going on
it's difficult to monitor so i i have
kind of basically a
relatively broad-based portfolio to
capture some of that move when the tail
goes up i either furthest risk out and
that happens in credit markets equity
markets all over the place in equity
markets in a in a bull market you tend
to get the big leaders first which is
where the safe money is the blue chips
then eventually people move to emerging
markets and then they move to frontier
markets and it's in order to get more
bang for your buck in the middle of the
cycle and generate some alpha so it's
not a it's not a comment per se on my
relative view on the success of
protocols or something like bitcoin it's
nothing to do with that it's about how
do i
make money
out of this crypto investment whilst
maintaining my my um level of interest
in the overall crypto world and so
that's where i am now where would it be
in a year's time maybe it's much more
bitcoin again so it's just that it's an
asset allocation strategy to try and
enhance rewards when you think about us
now in a bear uh bull market make sense
why you're allocated the way you are
will you then look to kind of
consolidate into the large caps in
a bear market if you think that's where
we're headed or do you yeah or like how
do you think about the transition i'm
trying to get my head around this
and i'm thinking that
yes i will move down the risk curve back
to the safer assets where i think
there's less volatility you can use you
know some yield from stable coins or
staking or whatever to lower your
volatility and then you want to be
looking to buy the speculative end of
the market that's going to get destroyed
whether it's parts of the nft space or
parts of the kind of general token space
that gets destroyed in the next bear
market to buy those when they're heavily
discounted but they still have network
adoption effects or some perceived value
or cash flow
that becomes really interesting because
then you can start allocating in the
middle of a bear market into the riskier
assets to buy them super cheap and
that's typical of credit markets
and equity markets people always do the
same and that's where you get the alpha
from is getting this asset allocation
right
and very few people do it because
they're they're still a little bit
blink into one project and the idea is
you can believe the whole space goes up
you can even have total belief in one
project but it's a long time to get
there so
is your allocation weighted correctly
for you to reduce the volatility a bit
so you can sleep at night in the bad
times and get a bit of extra out
performance in the good times rule
number two embrace accessibility with
michael saylor i think a bitcoin is like
that shining city in cyberspace
where billions of people will eventually
want to live
right instead of moving from europe to
america or moving from the old world to
the new world or whatever we're moving
from
the planet to cyberspace we can't move
to outer space yet i can't get a billion
people off the planet and settle on a
better earth
but i can move a billion people to
cyberspace
bitcoin is property in cyberspace
it's 21 million city blocks in cyber
manhattan
um
the people that move there first
right get to buy the land cheapest
and then event you know how many people
will eventually want to live there
well unlike manhattan where there's a
limit there's really no limit why
wouldn't everybody want to live there
right i mean
i don't know that there won't be other
cities in cyberspace that that might
meet other needs i mean i suppose if the
chinese
you know made it illegal to own bitcoin
but there was a chinese bitcoin there
might be a chinese version of bitcoin in
cyberspace kind of like
alibaba you know and ant and and wechat
kind of branched off from facebook and
google and amazon
so there might be some other digital
dominant monetary networks or dominant
monetary networks but but bitcoin is the
greatest
the greatest
monetary network that the human race has
ever developed and it's certainly the
dominant one right now and it looks like
it's going to be continued to be the
dominant one
for as long as we live
so um
what makes it uh
dominant
well i mean clearly the the architecture
is a proof of work or in other words
throwing up a wall of encrypted energy
right it's all of
the crypto hash power that's channeling
energy through the hashing function
which creates
uh creates the stability and the
security
and so
it's based upon the architecture
but um but ultimately the appeal of it
is that it's an open permissionless
protocol that everybody on earth can
engage in
anybody can mine it anybody can so
anybody can contribute security to the
network
and anybody can run their own node and
anybody can own it and then any company
uh can plug into it
and so there's nothing that open there
is not there is no monetary protocol or
asset or currency that is so open
as the bitcoin asset
and so that's what's driving its value
right now
it's
it's an opportunity for people that are
that have little
that have little to lose and much to
gain it's all it's an opportunity for
everybody though i mean the way i think
of it is it's a moral imperative a
technical imperative and an economic
imperative
morally it's an imperative because it's
it's the best hope for eight billion
people to secure their property rights
if i give you a fifty dollar android
phone you can carry around in the
android wallet your property
and no bank
or no hostile regime can seize it
and we've never and that's the best
property right you're ever gonna get
i think it's a technical imperative for
the same reason you've got eight billion
mobile phones
that will all have property and so
what's more important storing your
photos and your videos on your mobile
phone or storing all your money
all your life force on your mobile phone
i mean you're worried about losing the
photos you took on your iphone you
worried about losing your life savings
clearly it's more valuable so
so it's a it's a technology imperative
for an apple and amazon and google and
facebook and companies like square and
paypal and binance and coinbase are
already extraordinarily successful by
embracing it you can see that right now
and finally it's an economic imperative
because there's 500 trillion dollars
worth of uh fiat derivatives cash and
bonds and stocks and real estate that's
valued based upon cash flows and all of
those things are being devalued at one
percent a month
something so
we can go back and forth over what's the
rate of currency expansion but
you know it's it's not that hard to see
that this is a 25 to 50 trillion dollar
a year problem
for anybody with assets on earth
it's very rare that you find it a
technology that's the solution to every
rich person's problem and every poor
person's problem simultaneously rule
number three consider growth with kyle
simani
today is pretty close to blue chip
within crypto i mean it's number six or
number seven you know on market cap so
it's pretty high up there um
the opportunity from here is now what's
the upside is it at its peak and you
know the primary way to think about
solana is relative to east
um
today the market capital soul is 12 or
13 of ethereum's thereabouts
um
and uh
you know obviously the barriers will say
it should be one percent the bulls will
say it should be equal to ethereum i
mean you have to render your own
judgment of how this thing is going to
stack up and rank
i would say six months ago it was still
uh extremely non-consensus to
acknowledge that something was going to
give ethereum a run for its money
um today i think uh there are uh i think
a lot of intellectual capital within
crypto believes solana is going to
coexist with ethereum um will it
displace ethereum i don't know i i think
it's actually pretty improbable there's
so much inertia
around the ethereum ecosystem i don't
think that can be displaced
but
uh
it's very clear that this thing is going
to coexist solana today is growing at an
extremely rapid pace um users being
onboarded assets um being issued stable
coins going into it
all of these things look at the last 90
days it's just vertical line from call
it uh a billion in assets to like 10
billion
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four invest in safe
assets with anthony scaramucci you can
move uh bitcoin you could move a billion
dollars of bitcoin instantaneously
it settles very quickly you can move it
for five dollars there's six or so
transactions that happen on the
blockchain that clear it uh it's
absolutely safe uh and secure and so
that's going to revolutionize the way
people uh move money around for
transferring of goods and services
moreover
whether we like it or not in the united
states dollar supremacy
there's great consternation by many
other countries related to dollar
supremacy and so you could see an
incentive for other countries to want to
trade in something like bitcoin rule
number five hold decentralized wallets
with kevin o'leary what's your read on
the launch of the bitcoin etf and the
impact on the market
i like it
as an indicator that the regulator is
warming up to finally um
you know providing guidance and
regulation
for the real thing i don't like it as a
product if i'm going to be exposed to
the price of bitcoin why don't i just
buy bitcoin and so the futures market is
very efficient but sometimes when prices
are very volatile not so much and so
look it's great that this it's clearly
reflected in the overall price of
bitcoin with the optimism globally that
the us regulator is finally going to get
behind cryptocurrency it's not just
bitcoin and it's a first baby step but
frankly you can buy an etf with the real
thing underlying up in canada right now
and other countries are doing that even
with ethereum now in canada so you know
hopefully within 24 months which is sort
of my time view we're going to have the
real thing
bitcoin inside an etf wrapper that
allows people with equity portfolios to
buy it and get price exposure
to the price of bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies it's not a bad thing
you can't say it's bad but it's not the
way i i don't want to invest in it that
way and why pay the fees why don't you
just buy bitcoin and hold it in a
decentralized wallet and i think that's
the most efficient way to do it rule
number six get custody of your asset
with anthony pompliano when you look at
bitcoin specifically
it has a financial component that is
unavailable in other assets it is
systematically built
to continue to protect your purchasing
power and protect could also just be
going sideways right just it doesn't
degrade it happens to be going up a lot
now because it's being repriced by the
world but at some point it'll reach some
stable value and it'll kind of just go
sideways and it'll protect that
purchasing power really important
concept
the second is this idea of sovereignty
so like you talked about putting that 19
in the bank and you couldn't get it out
huge problem right a lot of people don't
know um i i've got a friend mark gusco
who talks all the time about like when
you put money into a bank account it's
not your money anymore that's crazy
right it's an iou they're supposed to
give it back to you
but we've seen and very kind of outlier
events like in cyprus in 2013 i think it
was where they basically come in and the
government says you know what if you
have a hundred dollars in the bank we're
taking ten dollars ten percent tax
across the board
well how can they take my money because
it's not your money right and so you you
end up not understanding some of that
and so this idea of sovereignty the
ability to hold your assets yourself
right you talked about you don't
actually have money buried in the
backyard right that would make you a
sovereign individual it also puts you at
a lot of security risk right somebody
could come here and dig it up and and uh
harm you et cetera
with bitcoin what it allows for is uh
this sovereignty you can actually hold
on to it nobody else is holding it for
you get to custody the asset and so in
the developed world we don't think a lot
about this right we just i put money in
the bank i go to the atm i can take it
out i can swipe a card you know no
problem
in the developing world this is a huge
problem right if all of a sudden i need
to get up and i need to flee venezuela
for example well i have to get on a
train a plane a boat or walk and at
every single one of the ports airports
train stations or border crossings what
are they doing they're confiscating
people's wealth and so there's you know
report after report after a report over
the last few years where somebody went
to the airport and they had physical
gold in their suitcase and and the uh
you know government or the military took
it from them
well you don't have sovereignty over the
asset because you don't have the
security of it and so bitcoin having
this cryptographic kind of security to
it ends up being really really important
on a global basis and rule number seven
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is spread out your risk with
robert breedlove it's not black or white
it's not like
banks or bitcoin you actually have
bitcoin banks they already exist um you
know nidig and all these other guys
they're just taking custody of bitcoin
now giving you traditional banking
services but on a bitcoin standard
uh the other aspect is it's not
you don't have one pot of bitcoin you
know you can put a little this bank that
bank this bank you can spread out your
counterparty risk
keep someone called self-custody
i mentioned multi-signature earlier that
might be a little bit beyond the scope
of this conversation but you can
actually get redundancy plus
self-sovereignty so you could trust
yourself but not make your house a
target by using a multi-signature setup
which i think is the most
uh useful
schema for custodying your bitcoin
because you get again redundancy you
don't have single point of failure but
you also don't have counterparty risk or
you have that's going out to like my
friends or my family and saying hey you
five or six people
you also have to sign for this to be
moved and one of you hopefully goes did
tom really want this
right that's what multi-sig is correct
yeah you're you're selecting your circle
of trust basically uh and structuring it
in a way that
a majority would not collude against you
or yeah and they don't probably even
know who each other are exactly and
there's a whole lot of game theoretic
considerations to that but it can be
done is the point um and bitcoin enables
us you can't do that with any of any
other asset so
that's radically
new i bought bitcoin in 2014.
so just i just need i just need all of
you to eat that for a minute
okay
i love showing my coinbase to people
like
i put in 25k it's worthless
[Applause]
so
marcus listen i i think blockchain's way
bigger than people realize like people
are with it like on a bitcoin level then
let people a little smarter on the
ethereum level but when you understand
what the blockchain is
my big thing with the blockchain is
it can it can literally overthrow
america and china and russia it's that
powerful it's a platform of trust
and we can do [ __ ] with each other and
everybody else is out
it's so heavy man
i haven't like i understand it
theoretically i haven't spent a lot of
time in it right
but
i've been spending more lately you know
there's a lot of [ __ ] icos get rich
quick [ __ ] that's starting to happen
i need all the dust thank you i need all
the dust to settle a little bit i'm
watching you know my favorite time is
when i'm like the cobra in the grass
i loved social media like two thousand
six seven eight because i was just like
creeping i was like in there i was
watching it
like that time with blockchain right now
that's how i'm with ar it's how with
voice i'm a little louder because i was
in the grass two years ago with voice
and alexa skills and podcasts but now
i'm out i think it's super fascinating i
think there's a lot of people that know
a lot more than me which is why i don't
spit on it a whole lot but it's big big
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to know what billionaires think of
cryptocurrency and if it's too late
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there well
look elon has tons of money and he's
very sophisticated so you know i'm i
don't worry that uh you know his bitcoin
will sort of randomly go up or down